[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight it's Monday
we just had a vacation so we're trying
to think a little more broadly about
what's happening in this world here's
where you come up with if you had to
boil down the Democratic Party's long
term goals to the most important goals
the first would be this and it's obvious
the federal government ought to cover
the essentials of life for most people
health care college housing food in some
cases a guaranteed basic income that's
the program the Democrats espouse
another word for it might be socialism
the party's other long-term goal is the
elimination of meaningful restrictions
on immigration into this country get rid
of ice except most refugees give
citizenship to tens of millions of
people here illegally in other words
open borders so those are the Democrats
main priorities a massive social welfare
state and millions of new citizens from
the third world nobody is hiding that
we're not making it up they're saying it
out loud the problem is that those two
goals conflict with each other
you can either admit the world's poor
into your country or you can give your
own people more free stuff but you can't
do both the math doesn't work socialism
with open borders is impossible it has
never worked and it never will work
anyone who thinks about that for about a
minute understands it so the idea is
fatally flawed the question is how do
you sell a program that can never
actually work well you lie about it you
pretend that what's obviously true isn't
true at all and you're evil for thinking
otherwise and of course that's exactly
what they're doing now watch DNC
spokesman Jim Acosta from earlier this
month scold the president for daring to
suggest that migrants from the imaginary
Caravan should it actually exist might
try to hop the US border your campaign
had an ad showing migrants climbing over
walls and so it for a but they were an
act they're not gonna be doing that
weren't accuracy well no it's just do
you think they were actors I they
weren't actors they didn't come from
Hollywood they're not gonna be doing
that as Democratic flack Jim Acosta
turns out that's precisely what they're
going to be
doing and just did over the weekend
American authorities had to shut down
the border crossing at San Ysidro
California retic next to San Diego after
about a thousand people tried to rush
the crossing watch so that's what the
DNC channels told us was never gonna
happen and of course it did happen and
it was bad Mexican riot police and the
US border agents both came under attack
from the mob which threw rocks at them
with no meaningful wall along the
borders authorities used tear gas to
disperse the crowd
now there's fairly recent precedent for
doing that in 2013 a group of about a
hundred people tried to rush the very
same border crossing at San Ysidro
American authorities forced them back
with pepper spray Barack Obama was
president at the time in the incident
past with little notice just five years
later there is a new president and an
entirely different standard the Left
erupted at these pictures of the tear
gas and accused the administration of
immoral atrocities Hawaii senator Brian
Schatz got so worked up he suggested
that American authorities had committed
a war crime by using illegal chemical
weapons he even mind these same
so-called chemical weapons are used
against unruly American citizens all the
time and nobody cares but those weren't
American citizens who just saw getting
tear gassed over the weekend they were
migrants they were holy men on a sacred
privilege pilgrimage north what happened
to them was inexcusable q the moral
outrage here we look at children get
being subjected to tear gassing that's
the United States causing that that's
outrageous we have seen the images of
the children and the women and there has
got to be a pragmatic and compassionate
answer here that does not involve tear
gassing children that is not who America
is that's not what America is declares
some random blowhard on CNN who has
somehow been deputized to lecture you
about what America is on the Left
America is always one thing for sure in
every case wrong watches this MSNBC
guest suggests that federal
Border Patrol agents must have been
lying about being attacked with rocks
those are questions whether or not
anyone actually threw rocks yesterday
NPR was reporting that actually it was
relatively peaceful yep relatively
peaceful except for this scene which
somehow didn't make it into many news
reports so well yes it turns out they
were in fact throwing rocks but
according to a lot of the analysis you
may have seen today it was in a peaceful
way gentle rock throwing really more
tossing than throwing playful actually
now here's a different perspective this
is from someone who was actually there
in San Ysidro and in contrast to the
people you just saw is not a
professional propagandist I kind of
challenge that this was a peaceful
protest or the majority of these people
were claiming asylum we ended up making
about 42 arrests only eight of those
were females and there were only a few
children involved the vast majority the
people were dealing with their adult
males one of the groups that I watched
the one of the groups that actually
several of them were arrested they
passed 10 or 15 marked border patrol
units walking east to west or west to
east I'm sorry numerous uniformed
personnel as they were chanting waving
the Honduran flag and throwing rocks at
the agents if they were truly asylum
seekers they would have just walked up
with her hands up and surrendered and
that did not take place what I find
unconscionable is that would people
would intentionally take children into
this situation what we saw over and over
yesterday was that the group the caravan
as we call them would push women and
children towards the front and then
begin basically rocking our agents so
there you have it well let you reach
your own conclusions about who is
telling the truth about what's happening
right now in our southern border check
the video before you make up your mind
but as you ponder it step back and ask
yourself some more fundamental questions
is there a natural limit to this kind of
immigration how many resources does
America really have to share with the
rest of the world are we as rich as we
assume we are are you how many poor
people can we realistically
cept before we're not that rich at all
but increasingly resemble the countries
from which these people are fleeing and
by the way if accepting more poor people
really makes you more prosperous then
what exactly has happened in California
over the past 30 years which despite
record levels of immigration is poorer
than ever now it's possible there are
good answers to these questions logical
answers on the other hand if there are
answers why is the left trying to
prevent you from asking the questions